levanten la mano aquella persona que ha
tenido un problema y no tenido nada más
que afrontarlo y lo ha logrado superar
si se dan cuenta somos todos
resulta que un día me dijeron
felicidades ya soy diseñador ese día fue
el día de mi graduación cuando realmente
ese día empezó el camino que me ha
traído hasta aquí el día de hoy
tengo que aclarar que voy a hablar en
plural muchas veces porque dos días
después de mi graduación se cumple la
promesa de mamá que me iba a casar hasta
que me graduara y me acompañan a mi
esposa que es mi equipo y con quien
hemos desarrollado muchos de los
proyectos de mi vida
voy a compartirles tres ideas la primera
de ellas
trata sobre la definición de diseño y lo
que quiero que ustedes comprendan como
comprendido
en 1919 en la primera escuela de diseño
y uno de sus profesores dice que el
diseño
no es una profesión es una actitud que
todos debemos de tener qué es la actitud
del planificador al leer estas palabras
me cuestión de esa definición que
durante años en la escuela de ciu me
habían inculcado sobre qué es diseño y
algo que sí me enseñaron en la escuela
también es que el diseñador lo primero
que hace es investigar ante cualquier
duda y empezamos a investigar así que
decidí empezar a investigar cuándo es
que el ser humano emprendió con esta
actitud de planificar me fui hasta la
prehistoria y me di cuenta que el ser
humano transita de ser nómada a
sedentario
gracias a la primera acción de diseño
que fue esa encontrar en su entorno un
objeto que podía modificar y le va
ayudar a cazar su alimento pero no
solamente eso
evolucionó esa idea el revolucionado es
herramienta para ser una herramienta
agrícola y así surge la gran primera
revolución de la humanidad que es la
agricultura y ganadería y gracias a esa
primera acción es que ahora las
sociedades han evolucionado como las
conocemos
entonces entendí que no solo los que
estamos diseño podemos diseñar tengo acá
una serie de rostros que luego de las
charlas de ahora de andrés iris lula y
alfredo debo de incluirlos ahí todas
estas personas han creado algo que ha
modificado la historia la humanidad para
ponerles un ejemplo una mujer que
observando a los niños diseñó un modelo
de educación vigente y que es aplicado
en todo el mundo ella es maría
montessori y quisiera contarles más
esperadas por eso me han dado 15 minutos
para hacerlo
y quiero contar la mía
obvio
seguí investigando y me encontré con
esos tres referentes que fundamentan la
locura que les estoy presentando en 1970
víctor papá nec empieza a cuestionar a
los diseñadores profesionales y les dice
si ustedes dedicarán el 10% de su tiempo
en resolver necesidades reales este
mundo sería distinto
luego tenemos a víctor margolín que es
otro teórico que rescata pensamientos
utópicos de lázsló moholy nagy de como
eres a una sociedad perfecta y él nos
plantea tres escenarios podemos hacer
acciones individuales que es lo que uno
hace en su metro cuadrado y cómo va
modificando su realidad luego tenemos un
nivel medio que es cuando te juntas con
un grupo de compañeros de personas como
una comunidad y empezás a resolver los
problemas y el tercer nivel que es el
nivel macro que lo hace ya como una
sociedad o como lula decía porque no
como un país
entonces
estamos los diseñadores profesionales
que nos forman para crear estas
herramientas complejas pensando en
cadenas productivas en comercialización
qué es lo que plantea ese omán cine pero
también plantea que hay otro tipo de
diseñador que es el diseñador que se
aprovecha de su entorno de la necesidad
y transforma todo para solventar esas
necesidades este diseño esto es la
actitud del planificador
y aquí va la segunda idea en mi vida
siempre renunciando a muchas cosas y lo
hago porque necesito hacer un cambio
porque llega un punto que
pierdo como emoción de las cosas y anna
me ha enseñado a siempre poner una meta
más alta y más alta
cuando salí a la universidad tuve la
oportunidad de trabajar para una ong que
me permitió recorrer todo el país y
conocer comunidades artesanales la vida
maya diseñar mejor sus productos
encontrando las materias primas a
hacerles ver que lo que os hacen tiene
un potencial para salir adelante
pero resulta que todos los de todos los
artesanos siempre tenían un problema y
como uno es el diseñador le preguntan
cómo puede resolverlo
entre esos problemas sonaba mucho que no
hay materia prima en el salvador
estaba cómodo tenía un trabajo estable
pero decidí renunciar y decidí emprender
otra investigación
me puse a pensar qué es lo que abunda en
el país qué es lo que realmente todos
producimos día con día y me encontré
basura
todos comemos y generamos desperdicio
constantemente entonces el artesano no
había visto que hay un potencial en su
entorno gracias a este cartón de huevos
surgen estas lámparas que se llaman ch
0-7
esa fórmula química es donde huevos 2007
gracias a estas lámparas pude salir de
este país de las fronteras y recorrer el
mundo a través de ferias de diseño puede
estar en nueva york puede estar en
londres puede estar en alemania y mi
sorpresa es que la gente consume basura
cara
la gente quiere este tipo de productos
me emocioné pasé 34 años en ferias pero
llegó un punto que hice esta lámpara que
fue cool me dije guau hoy si lo logré
nadie reconocía la basura no sé si
ustedes la ven pero son botes de vélez
rosita para lavar ropa solo del mango
que sea un nido con módulos como
metieron una escuela de diseño o aplicar
los principios de diseño pero no me
sentí feliz porque en ese momento me
acordé que víctor papá nec decía diseñar
cosas necesarias no bonitas no
funcionales y en ese momento me acordé
de los artesanos y dije que estoy
haciendo acá irónicamente hay
detractores o hay gente que cuestiona
porque uno renuncia porque por una
escuela de diseño tener un graduado que
salen libros que sale en revistas que
salen blog es un diseñador exitoso
pero yo decidí renunciar para emprender
el camino en el que estoy ahora me
dedique el 100% del tiempo a la docencia
y es aquí la tercera idea
el diseño como factor de cambio social
gracias a estas ferias descubrí que las
hadas madrinas existen
ella es una persona real ella es mi hada
madrina se llama caribe phillips es una
inglesa alemana jubilada que decidió
emprender muchas ongs una de ellas es
ayudando a los artesanos y burkina faso
otra es ayudando a los migrantes
africanos en francia y la tercera es el
british european design group que
promueve a los diseñadores emergentes
ella fue la que creyó en nuestro trabajo
y ella fue la que me permitió ir de
feria en feria mostrando estas lámparas
pero un día me cuestiono y me dijo
eugenio tu pasado tanto te ha dado tanto
y te ha hecho lo que sos que están
haciendo ustedes cuál es el legado que
dejan a las futuras generaciones eso me
hizo volver a ver mi país y quería hacer
proyectos para nuestro país y gracias al
área granadino que ilustró también el
salvador me demostró que es un
territorio chiquitito y que el mejor
lugar para hacer diseño porque si
ustedes se preguntan qué es lo que
necesita un diseñador para hacer son
problemas y aquí
tendremos hasta para regalar
entonces cuando karim me dijo eso me
puse a pensar ya no estoy mi metro
cuadrado ya estoy trabajando como una
comunidad de nivel medio y es como
vinieron la introducción pensé en los
estudiantes decidiste el profesor porque
así puedo incidir en la mente de más
personas y empezar a cambiar la manera
de pensar y así ya no voy a hacer socio
quién está trabajando sino que tengo
colegas a la par mía porque yo sí creo
que todos somos diseñadores y creo que
mis estudiantes ya son diseñadores así
que me junte con rectores de las
universidades que ofrecen la carrera de
diseño en el país y les plantee un
proyecto de diseño para la movilidad el
tema movilidad lo planteó ves yo manchin
en una conferencia haciendo tener
referencia a los nómadas que pasan a ser
sedentarios e inclusive nuestros días
estamos viendo migraciones salvadoreñas
en caravanas hacia eeuu es un tema muy
vigente para el diseño y le planteó el
reto a un grupo de 10 estudiantes de dos
universidades de dos carreras
y ellos que son los que investigan ahora
ya no soy yo encuentran en la producción
de café
un lugar ideal para generar un proyecto
porque hay muchas personas involucradas
en el proceso quien nadie se preocupa
por sus necesidades
específicamente ellos se enfocaron en
los cortadores de café entonces ya
ustedes saben que esta gente ande en
barrancos cortando el café lo mete en un
saco de más de 100 libras y se lo
avientan sobre la espalda causando daños
en las cervicales cuando ellos son
mayores tienen problemas otro problema
es que ellos andan con canastos de 25 a
30 libras con un cinturón que les
aprieta la piel porque no está diseñado
para la anatomía del cuerpo salvadoreño
en ese tipo de cosas es lo que se fijan
los diseñadores y los niveles como
ustedes pueden ver ahí están incluye a
los cortadores porque es una
comunicación entre diseñador y usuario
quien le va a dar la solución
así como tú por día de ir a la feria de
y que teníamos que aplicar aún a esta
feria de diseño está una feria 100
comercial y nos atrevimos a llevar un
proyecto con enfoque 100% social cuál
fue nuestra sorpresa
que todos esos productos robustos
causaron cierta confusión en las
personas pero también nos dimos cuenta
que las personas a nivel mundial quieren
consumir diseño social
por cierto andando de estos jóvenes ahí
sentados entre ustedes
kevin y fátima
qué sucedió cuando regresamos de la
feria
nos dimos cuenta
y en el salvador también hay gente
interesada y los estantes me preguntaban
y qué más van a hacer yo quiero ser
parte de este proyecto lo que fue una
motivación para las instituciones ya no
era nada más mi locura es lo que la
locura de dos universidades que cree en
el proyecto que dijeron hagamos
nuevamente el proyecto pero como han
enseñado no lo pongan más fácil ponerlo
más complicado
les planteamos el tema de diseño para la
vulnerabilidad
pero el diseño necesita tener limitantes
y no queremos la vulnerabilidad de todo
el país decidimos la vulnerabilidad en
la zona costera
específicamente en comunidades que
tienen algún tipo de vulnerabilidad los
jóvenes se pusieron a investigar y
encontraron en el sexto objetivo de
desarrollo de la onu el aporte de
innovación que es el tema del agua y el
saneamiento
como diseñador es lo primero que hacemos
es investigar toda la red de actores que
se van a ver involucrados porque
diseñamos todos en conjunto tenemos ongs
gobierno local los adecos familias y
entre todos ellos se generan las
soluciones
qué sucedió cuando empezamos a hacer
este proyecto los estudiantes hicieron
una inversión en el contexto y vieron
cuál era la necesidad vieron que la
gente recolecta el agua y la mayoría son
mujeres porque los jefes de hogar en
este país son mujeres recolectan el agua
y la conservan entonces de un problema
de purificar el agua pero entre más
investigaron dieron cuenta que también
es un problema en el sistema de
distribución de agua y fue como uno de
esos actores que es una empresa social
junto con la comunidad el tecolote monte
sinaí y playa majagual están diciendo la
carpeta técnica para poder luego buscar
financiamiento para tener un sistema de
agua sostenible
que nos damos cuenta aquí que no era
nada más como estudiantes creían diseñar
un filtro comercial que al vender iba a
financiar un filtro social que llegara a
las familias nos dimos cuenta que
nuestro proyecto va mucho más allá
nuestro proyecto ahora en primera fase
está divulgando lo que pasa en el país
estamos divulgando que hay 500 niños que
mueren por problemas gastrointestinales
a causa del agua que hay 35 por ciento
de población rural con acceso al agua el
resto de la tiene y que el 40 por ciento
del agua en el país está contaminada
y si también lo llevamos a una feria
donde hemos dado cuenta que la mejor
manera de divulgar nuestros proyectos es
exponerlos al mundo cuál fue la sorpresa
en esta feria que no nada más querían
consumir sino social nos preguntaban
cómo le puedo comprar nos preguntaban
cómo puedo darle dinero para financiar
su proyecto en este método dimos cuenta
que la cosa grande y qué más pasó los
muchachos se ganaron el premio este el
equivalente a lotería en estas ferias
los editores de las revistas más
prestigiosas premian a la mejor escuela
y nuestro proyecto si jóvenes
salvadoreños ganaron ese premio y son
reconocidos como ganadores a nivel
mundial
[Música]
nuestro papel como universidades y
llevar el diseño a las sociedades de
mostrarles a ustedes que ustedes son
diseñadores y que deben de unirse a
nosotros y generar cada vez más
proyectos porque el diseño no va a
salvar el mundo
nosotros estamos cambiándolo y quiero
cerrar con las palabras que me dio una
vez
la que fue mi directora en la escuela de
diseño
al ser humano antes de este diseñador
perdón hay que hacer seres humanos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]